broken city does look interesting has a  solid premise solid characters i love  marky mark say how do you mother for me  andy sandberg russell crowe is back in  corrupt bad guy fashion and catherine  zeta jones is back where the [ __ ] has  she been the thing that worries me about  this movie though is it looks a lot like  a b movie which makes it look like an  okay movie sort of looks like a hard  justice exploitation film but it could  be a good january movie and like i  always say january is the month where  hollywood takes a [ __ ] and releases it  to the world but who knows with this  cast they tend to choose their movies  wisely except for catherine's david  jones and rock of ages oh that's where  she's been i'm gonna go ahead and give  this film a chance all in all i gotta  say broken city looks like it could get  it right [ __ ]  you